[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande inteview le liban ce petit pays
du moyen-orient qui a eu tout juste cent
ans elian un peu plus d'une semaine un
pays qui a vécu plusieurs guerres une
ville beyrouth qui a été détruite et
reconstruite plusieurs fois aussi on la
compare souvent au phénix qui renaît de
ses cendres un pays précurseur de médias
dans le monde arabe
connu pour sa musique ou encore sa
gastronomie mais depuis quelques années
le pays s'enfonce dans une grave crise
économique et sociale
le 4 août une double explosion ravages
beyrouth faisant 191 morts plus de 6500
blessées et 300 mille sans abri les
libanais tentent aujourd'hui de panser
leurs plaies
la nouvelle génération se bat pour
sortir d'un système politique corrompu
dans lequel ils ne se reconnaissent pas
aujourd'hui notre invité fait partie de
cette génération et qui veut un liban
meilleur nous accueillons dans la grande
interview mots in jaber 29 ans
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur arte france dans la grande interview
mots in jaber vous avez 29 ans vous êtes
à diplômé en économie et passionné de
médias numériques vous êtes activistes
pour l'association emmène tes chine qui
est née pendant la révolution et qui
aident à reconstruire
abbey road vous êtes toujours sur le
terrain et pourtant vous n'étiez pas
prédestiné à ce destin là cinquante
mille libanais ont quitté le pays
la question peut paraître trop naïve
mais pourquoi être resté au liban
bonjour moi l'a déjà comment voulez vous
que je quitte un pays qui a été meurtri
comme ça c'est on vient une catastrophe
et ça fait un bon moment que le riz
surtout que je suis très investi depuis
la révolution je suis très impliqué ça
fait depuis le 17 octobre que je suis
dans la rue et aujourd'hui je suis co
fondateur d'un mouvement politique de
jeunes quand vous avez dit qu'il
s'appelle mai tai chi linh mateschitz ça
veut dire d'octobre et ça veut aussi
dire répondu vu que la révolution était
un mouvement populaire on a essayé de
s'organiser
j'ai fait connaissance à des gens dans
la rue des professionnels des docteurs
des
des des avocats des professionnels dans
tous les secteurs et on a essayé de
créer un parti politique qui ressemble
notre société parce que comme vous le
savez on a des partis politiques
traditionnels qui ont été créés durant
la guerre qui nous représente plus
depuis le 4 août c'est un peu le jour où
tout a basculé au liban c'est une
journée digne d'un film d'horreur cette
double explosion des routes éventrées
les rues jonchées de cadavres de débris
de sang de verre à ce moment là où
étiez-vous et donc le 4 août c'est pas
vraiment un film c'est plutôt là haut
calibre à
il y aura toujours un avant avant 4 août
1 après 4 août
ce jour là j'étais au travail et chaque
jour je fais là le trajet à côté du port
où l'explosion a eu lieu
mais ce jour là j'ai pris quatre minutes
a commandé à quelque chose on line et
normand si j'avais pas commander
j'aurais été au port j'aurais été peut
être les figures et blesser ou même mort
ce qui se passe et c'était vraiment une
catastrophe humaine
madame trahi les jeux mais aisés sont
des quartiers qui ont été les plus
touchés ce qui sont à côté du port et
s'est déclaré fier normalement habitée
par des gens qui ont 60 ans soixante dix
ans et 80 en jeu
j'ai conservé mes parents mais mon frère
mes amis pour savoir si c'était 6 et tcf
et a menacé rien ne s'est passé avec
comme est directement je suis parti pour
voir si je pouvais aider des gens juste
pour cette sortie quand vous êtes sorti
quelle vision vous avez eu bat du vert
partout du sang partout je suis parti
pour voir les hôpitaux et les hôpitaux
elle était vraiment plein de gens des
docteurs qui était en train de se
soigner en train de se faire en train de
soigner des gens
c'était vraiment l'apocalypse n'y a pas
de film d'horreur qui peut vraiment
décrire ce qui s'est passé mais la
solidarité libanaise suivant cette
catastrophe a été la chose qui m'a sauvé
moi honnêtement il ya eu beaucoup de
moments miraculeux il ya beaucoup de
gens qui étaient censés faire des ventes
qu'il aurait annulé à la dernière minute
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sait pas qui
est qui et qui ont eu un changement
d'itinéraire et beaucoup de gens ont été
sauvés mais malheureusement il ya
toujours deux cents morts et 400 mille
déplacés
il ya 7000 blessé et c'est très
difficile
maureen vous parlez de solidarité qu'est
ce qui vous a le plus touché finalement
il ya eu aussi beaucoup de dons de la
part de l'étranger ya aussi eu les les
libanais de l'étranger qui ont voulu
s'investir et des liban voilà déjà il ya
plus de lits d'aller en dehors du liban
qu'il ya des bêtes dans le liban la
diaspora énorme et je pense que le truc
le plus difficile pour la des sports à
ces deux voies une catastrophe comme
celle là et de ne pouvoir rien faire et
ils ont créé des campagnes pour pouvoir
financer reconstruire et le liban dans
le liban il ya eu un mouvement ceux de
solidarité de vraiment admirable en
l'absence de l'état on a voulu aider les
gens l'état n'a rien fait il a été
complètement silencieux durant les les
quatre premiers jours et ccc le je ne
sais pas comment dire le le vouloir
civique des gens du liban qui a vraiment
poussé à reconstruire toute la ville
chaque jour je descendais à 6h30 du
matin avec des amis à moi on l'est on
l'a commencée ont été vains et ensuite
c'était on était dans les milliers pour
pouvoir et bleu les gens justement parce
que les habitants du quartiers les plus
touchés c'est des gens qui ne pouvait
pas s'occuper de mamie des gens très
grand 60 ans 70 à 80 ans justement mise
moyenne je me permets de vous
interrompre pour vous
que l'état ne nous a pas aidés justement
on a vu beaucoup d'image de libanais qui
ramassait qui nettoyaient les rues
est-ce que la défiance est là encore
plus grande vis-à-vis de l'état après
cette explosion
bien sûr on le savait déjà qu'ils
pouvaient rien faire j'ai une
philosophie c'est la philosophie du de
la passion qu'est le cancer
on sait déjà que cette personne va
mourir si elle a le cancer
mais le jour où il meurt on est surpris
mais c'est comme ça avec l'état on sait
que l'état est corrompu on sait que
l'état est criminel mais dès qu'on voit
que l'état ne fait rien on est toujours
surpris et l'un des fiancés et encore
plus fort maintenant parce que ça nous à
reconfirmer encore une fois que l'état
n'ait ne sert à rien c'est l'état sert
juste à me tirer dessus quand on est en
train de de faire des démonstrations
pour pour vivre en dignité mais à tout
autre chose ils sont existants justement
on a vu ces images qui sont incroyables
qui glace le sang qui font froid dans le
dos vous en tant que libanais vous voyez
les gens autour de vous comment est-ce
qu'on se relève d'un tel choc
comment est ce qu'on continue à vivre
finalement c'est une bonne question
comment est ce qu'on continue à vivre la
seule façon dont que je sais pourquoi je
sais que je peux je suis entré d'autre
part et c'est à cause des gens qui
étaient autour de moi en en faisant de
bonnes choses on est des gens ça nous
permet de d'oublier toutes les choses
négatives au moins pour une façon
temporaire et je sais pas peut-être la
facture de mots psychologist de mon
psychologue pardon battre un peu un peu
un peu cher plus tard mais maintenant je
me concentre sur des choses qui vont se
passer maintenant je n'aurais pas
vraiment à long terme parce que je veux
pas le futur est incertain
on parlera de ce futur incertain mots in
je voudrais pas qu'on parle un petit peu
politique aujourd'hui la france et le
liban ont un lien historique on le sait
il ya eu de visite d' emmanuel macron la
première a été source d'espoir la
deuxième un peu plus déçu est-ce que
selon vous c'est le rôle de la france de
s'impliquer beaucoup parlé d'ingérence
française est ce que c'est votre avis
ok donc la france nous a mis sous un
protectorat c'est pas vraiment une
colonisation
les modélisations de macron son ont été
probablement sûrement même des
motivations économiques politiques et
géopolitiques
face à la turquie je pense que macron de
replacer la france dans l'équation du
moyen orient
c'est vrai qu'il dit là avec le régime
qu'on veut plus il leur a dit qu'il les
laisse sans pouvoir mais ils peuvent
plus prendre de l'argent ou être
corrompu il leur a dit aussi de former
un nouveau gouvernement
même si l'agencé française avait un but
économique et politique s'est ôté
c'était aussi bénéfique pour nous
quelque part parce que une heure comme
vous voyez
en parallèle il ya pomper l'eau qui a
mis des sanctions sur aller face intra
lille sur jeu blanc bec il va mettre
aussi sur jeu blanc décide il ya donc
une alliance entre la france et les
états unis et cette alliance cette
ingérence est peut-être mieux qu'une
ingérence entre je sais pas l'iran et la
chine
aujourd'hui où on préférait que vous
préférez que la france s'implique plutôt
que par exemple l'iran ou d'autres pays
comme la chine
oui parce que parce qu'on connaît la
france on connaît les états unis et mais
le gouvernement a été formé auprès de 24
heures
mais comme à cran leur a dit qu'ils
forment le gouvernement alors que sans
l'intervention française
le gouvernement de passer un diable le
premier ministre davant a pris 5 6 mois
donc une pression internationale est
toujours celle essayez toujours une
bonne chose me peuvent pas vraiment
changer quelque chose au sein de la
politique libanaise
maureen on va parler politique libanaise
justement pour ceux qui nous regardent
il faut qu'il faut le savoir pour
comprendre au liban il ya un système
multi confessionnel c'est à dire que
toutes les confessions doivent être
représentés il ya 18 confessions au
liban pour un pays de 5 millions
d'habitants qui fait à peu près la
taille de l'île de france donc c'est
énorme c'est beaucoup il faut que le
président soit chrétien le ministre du
par le premier ministre sunnite et le
président du parlement
shit pour que tout le monde soit
représenté 2
manière égale les libanais peuvent pas
voter directement pour leur président
ils votent pour des députés qui eux
votent pour le président c'est assez
irréel ce système là il a été validé par
la france en 1920 est-ce que selon vous
il est temps de changer de 2,6 système
politique et de système électoral bien
sûr il est temps de changer
on a toujours cohabité ensemble les
accords de taëf dans les années 1990
était un traité interlibanais destinée à
mettre fin à la guerre civile qui avait
eu lieu en 1975
mais ce système est vraiment c'est un
système ancien maintenant la nouvelle
génération ne pose pas des questions
comme est ce que vous êtes chrétien ou
est-ce que vous êtes musulman on s'en
fout on veut un état qui met la
souveraineté du citoyen au début parce
que cette classe politique a aussi
investi dans ce système
confessionnalisme ça fait 30 ans que ce
même régime est en train de renier il ne
divise pour mieux régner
c'est la même classe qui gouverne ce
système confessions et ça crée un
système tentaculaire où la corruption
touche le plus petit le plus petit donc
fonctionnaires de l'état et c'est juste
à travers un état civil qu'on peut
vraiment développé comme ça comme une
société on peut plus le sunnite chiite
chrétiens cc c'est toujours très
important mais c'est pas la priorité
et les jeunes le savent justement
aujourd'hui la génération elle veut d'un
d'un système laïc par exemple je sais
que michel arnaud président la
république en a vraiment su enfin on
avait parlé mais je vois sourire c'est
pas vraiment un président
je sais pas c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui
justifie désordre c'est pas lui qui les
donne à 100% qu'il ya 84 c'est une
personne qui a 84 ans qui on dirait
qu'il n'est pas vraiment lucide quand
quand on lui fait un entretien il sait
pas vraiment lui qui en pouvoir c'est
plutôt la classe politique dont la
bibere le chef du parlement dont je
blâme glace il est toute une oligarchie
de gens qui prennent davantage dans
notre président et c'est très frustrant
parce que dès qu'on essaie de changer
quelque chose ils essayent de nous taire
avec la violence parce que c'est le seul
langage qu'ils comprennent c'est la
violence et donc c'est pour ça que des
comptes décent pour faire des
démonstrations on on essaie d'être
toujours paisible on essaie de notre pas
partir à la violence parce que bien
évidemment c c'est leur façon de
communiquer nous on essaie de montrer
qu'on est l'exemple meilleure moyenne on
va marquer une courte pause et on
revient
[Musique]
on est de retour dans la grande
interview on est avec moïse jaber
activistes libanais de 29 ans qui nous
parle un petit peu de l'actualité au
liban mots in justement tout à l'heure
vous nous parler de corruption vous nous
parler de la jeunesse qui a envie d'un
renouveau politique
concrètement pour ceux qui ne savent pas
comment la vie se passe au liban qu'elle
est quel est votre quel est le quotidien
commence à être corruption elle se
traduit dans votre quotidien
tous les jours ok donc juste pour
contextualiser les chefs de guerre les
brûlots et ses pouvoirs même avant
l'accord de taëf et ils ont juste changé
leurs habits militaires avec des
cravates et des des chemises ils ont
divisé pour mieux régner
ces hommes politiques sont en train de
se battre pour des ministères par
exemple jab alain bassil se bat pour
avoir tout le mystère de l'énergie nabih
berry le chef du parlement se bat pour
avoir ministère des finances dont chaque
ministère fait partie d'un parti
politique et même la belgique comme ce
que tu peux avoir un chef du parlement
qui gérer cela en trente ans il a même
battu le guinness book des records
c'est ridicule et corinne vous en tant
qu' en tant que jeune activiste vous
voyez ce qui se passe autour de vous la
corruption vous la sentez comment au
quotidien c'est à dire si vous voulez
trouver un travail si vous voulez vivre
le coût de la vie comment ça se passe au
quotidien
bon pour travailler le salaire minimum
était de 550 mille livres et vu que ça a
changé depuis 550 prêts en dollars pour
qu'on ait ou en euros pour qu'on ait une
par exemple au travail si on travaillait
à 20 mille dollars par mois notre
salaire a perdu 60 au centre de sa
valeur dont on travers 300 dollars c'est
un changement
total est non seulement ça les prix ont
aussi augmenté donc on peut on peut plus
mollet le live ça qu'on avait et
maintenant être plus achetés dont on a
besoin et ça c'est pour une personne qui
gagne 1000 $ ce qui est aussi très
spéciale au liban c'est que les gens
mêlée enfin la société libanaise avait
mené plusieurs réalités économiques
il ya des gens qui gagna en dollars il y
avait des gens qui gagnait en livres
libanaises des gens qui gagnent en
dollars ont pu continuer leur vie mais
maintenant et ils peuvent que retirer
une certaine somme d'argent chaque jour
il ya une limite
alors que les gens qui gagnent en et en
livres libanaises ont perdu 60% de leur
mmorpg et ont dû changer leur live stade
aujourd'hui le quotidien d'un jeune
libanais c'est quoi quelqu'un qui vient
de sortir d'une université il effaça
quoi par exemple il est face au chômage
il est face au chômage il ya plus
d'opportunités au liban les hommes
politiques ont tout fait pour créer un
environnement in hospital pour pouvoir
vivre en dignité et la majorité des gens
80 % de ma promo de ma fac ont quitté le
liban est maintenant quand vous avez dit
il ya 5 550 milles où je pense même cent
mille personnes qui ont quitté le liban
parce qu'il ya plus d'avenir
il est jean melançon restent chez eux
ils ne sortent plus déjà parce que
comment est ce que tu peux vraiment
t'amuser vous sortiez au pays où partira
ce restaurant si il ya un mois il ya une
explosion atomique
il ya aussi un fait la population 50 %
de la population vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté aujourd'hui au liban il ya des
régions il ya ma d'électricité ce qu'on
peut nous parler un petit peu de de ces
gens qui parlent pas forcément qui n'ont
pas la parole
je sais pas si je peux parler
pour eux mais ils sont très frustrés pas
vraiment faire quelque chose parce que
les gens pauvres sont les gens les plus
susceptibles à la faim la corruption
c'est les gens avec qui les chefs de
gare peut parler avec et leur donner de
l'argent pouvoir vivre c'est les gens
qui sont toujours manipulés et pour eux
c'est vivre jours à jour c'est pouvoir
nourrir sa famille c'est ils peuvent pas
regarder ils peuvent pas faire réfléchir
à long terme ne peuvent pas réfléchir
aux élections parce qu'ils peuvent pas
leur situation économique ne leur permet
pas on a pas d'électricité on n'a pas de
l'eau on a on n'a rien pour pouvoir
vivre en dignité dans ce pays
c'est vraiment une catastrophe et ça
c'est ces mêmes avant la révolution
d'octobre 2010 9 c'est un système
gangréné qui a vraiment détruit tous les
secteurs économiques pour pouvoir régner
diviser pour mieux régner c'est c'est la
politique de faim maintenant c'est la
politique de est ce qu'il n'ya aussi du
favoritisme du clientélisme de la part
des députés qui pour quoi pour qu'on
pour qu'ils aient des voix peut-être
qu'ils placent plus de confession
quelque part est ce qu'il y ait ce
système là aussi de favoritisme bien sûr
et un système de favoritisme comme j'ai
dit avant chacun de politique à son à
son propre ministère je veux un bacille
à mystères de de l'énergie ma vie je
vais les doigts ali hassan khalil al
ministères des finances et des
télécommunications et divise et s'est
pas basée sur les compétences du
personnel basé sur l'alliance politique
c'est le clientélisme et c'est comme ça
qu'il qu'ils peuvent garder le contrôle
et dès que quelqu'un est compétent et
c'est de prendre cette position il a ils
font une campagne d'intimidation ou il
le tue c'est soit ça sur l'autre c'est
pour ça que ce système a pu vivre
pendant 30 ans et maintenant nous on
peut plus est
ses souvenirs de guerre vous faites vous
faites partie wine de cette nouvelle
génération la révolution d'octobre
elle a commencé en octobre 2019 qu'est
ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
et s'ils en restent bons débuts la
pandémie bien sûr de colette martin qui
à ralentir un peu les mouvements sur la
rue mais la révolution a pris un autre
visage
il ya des collisions ont été créés entre
des groupes de la révolution pour
pouvoir créer un vrai changement
[Musique]
ce qui est ce qui est important c'est de
savoir que ce système politique qui a eu
30 ans a régné ne peut pas être
complètement détruit dans deux ou trois
mois cc c'est quelque chose qui une
bataille qui est très longue qui a
besoin de patience j'espère que moi
aussi je cette patience je me donne deux
ans avant de quitter deux ans à venir
jusqu'à nous et les élections
légistatives les élections municipales
et peut-être même les élections
présidentielles s'il ne mord pas avant
notre président en notre président vous
en attendez de vous attendez quoi de ces
élections qui vont arriver ce que vous
avez espoir est sûre on a de l'espoir
c'est notre seule arme contre cette
organisation politique
le truc le plus important c'est de créer
de lutter pour l'indépendance de la
justice l'indépendance de la justice
n'existe pas le système judiciaire est
très très très politisée ça veut dire
que si on veut porter plainte contre
quelqu'un il faut payer de l'argent par
ici il faut parler avec cette affaire
par là dès qu'on a des concret ce
système d' indépendance judiciaire
on peut vraiment
développé en tant que pays et donc ce
que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août
c'est une mobilisation sociétal qui
n'existait pas avant quelques années
toutes les confessions se retrouver sur
la place des martyrs un certain chouhada
et tout le monde discute et finalement
tu mens discuter ils sont trouvés entre
le même drapeau libanais pour une fois
c'est pas le drapeau des partis
politiques qui est élevée c'est le sait
le drapeau libanais mais malheureusement
il ya eu aussi beaucoup de violence de
la violence départ des des systèmes
sécuritaires du liban à de la violence
de l'armée et donc l'activité où le
mouvement sur les rues mais pas aussi
fort qu'avant mais ça veut pas dire qu'
il n'y a pas d'activité ça veut dire
qu'on lance la violence de la part des
forces de l'ordre oui oui tellement de
violence cc je voyais des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
le temps ont changé mais je pense que
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée pour
créer ce cette séparation entre le
peuple et l'armée mais le peuple mais
l'armée fait partie du peuple et le
peuple fait partie de l'armée et donc
cesser c'est quelque chose de très
difficile on a train de se réconcilier
avec la avec l'armée mais c'est un
procès qui est très long à moi je
faisais partie des manifestations du 8
août et j'ai vu des membres de l'armée
tiré sur mes amis en train de jeter des
grenades sur des gens qui ne m'avaient
pas qu'ils n'étaient pas armés qui
voulait juste faire des démonstrations
pour une bombe atomique qui a détruit la
moitié de la capitale et la réponse
c'était le est tiré dessus
cc c'est absurde win on parle beaucoup
de bas de votre génération de votre
nouvelle génération vous discuté
beaucoup avec media a souri journaliste
votre binôme dans l'émission podcast
salle des actes dans un cadre un peu
intimiste avec des invités vous parlez
d'un peu de tout des tabous de la libre
c'est libanaise vous parlez de santé
économie écologie sexualité vous parler
un petit peu tout expliqué nous en
quelques mots ce concept là il est né
quand le bas le concept a toujours été
là c'est un concept que nous en tant que
peuvent méditer en méditerranée et en
graine est dans notre culture c'est de
juste parler ça soit après un dîner et
d'être vraiment vraiment très très
honnête parce que quand vous avez déjà
des sujets tabous qu'on ne paraît pas
devant les écrans de télé qu'on ne
parlera pas devant les gens mais qu'on
parle de façon très intime même
maintenant les conversations c'est des
conversations politiques si important
c'est de savoir que toutes les chaînes
de télé au liban sont des chaînes
extrêmement politisé bien sûr que c'est
logique qu'une chaîne de télé soit
possible mais au liban c'est un peu plus
prononcée
c'est c'est même un peu absurde et là ce
qu'on fait avec cbc avoir une
conversation l'homme point où une
personne peut non seulement dire leurs
sound rights mais ils ont montré comment
il pense est en train de ramener
beaucoup de gens on va ramener bien
tomihara leaf est une ex pointe ce drame
qui a été une partie vraiment très
importante pour construire le liban et
l'a vendu
les lunettes qu'elle est qu'elle portait
durant ces films pornos à 100 mille
dollars et ses cent mille dollars ont
été donnés à la croix rouge libanaise et
donc qu'est-ce qui est plus absurde
dites moi une expand ce qui est de liban
et qui donne plus de cent mille dollars
au peuple libanais ou un gouvernement
libanais qui en train de tirer sur ses
citoyens qui n'ont pas d'armes qui était
en train de faire des démonstrations
contre une explosion qui a détruit la
moitié de la cité
qu'est ce qui est plus absurde maureen
je vous laisse le soin de répondre à
cette question mais aujourd'hui vous
vous en
visage et l'avenir comment vous rêvez de
quel liban je rêve d'un liban où la
volonté du citoyen c'est la priorité
j'aurais d'un liban civile jardin liban
où la diversité c'est notre point fort
pas notre point faible un lit donc il
n'est pas esclave aux agendas politiques
d'autres pays
ali ben qui est célèbre à cause de la
créativité de son peuple et non pas les
guerres qui ont détruit le pays
tr min et mégane et si vous aviez un
dernier message à faire passer à la
classe politique libanaise
allez vous faire le bas des
trains europe
c'est la fin de leur chemin et on sait
très bien pourquoi il ya une escale à
sion de violence on sait très bien
pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus c'est
pas s'ils savent que c'est leur fin ils
se préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence il ne va pas
être violent mais on va rester
déjà la majorité de la classe politique
ces défauts si c'est des autos génère et
on l'attend soit ce qu'ils meurent sur
les ce qu'ils ont enlevés par force ou
soit par des élections légitimes
législatives avec un système judiciaire
qui va punir ceux qui ont volé liban et
mettre en pouvoir ce qu'ils aiment le
liban mois il jamais remercie pour ce
message d'espoir bon courage à vous dans
cette lutte
en tout cas merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette grande interview vous pouvez la
revoir sur rt france point tv
[Musique]
je